pour accéder à un site pornographique en
2022 rien de plus simple il suffit de
taper l'adresse est d'attester qu'on a
plus de 18 ans une facilité qui
révoltent marie mercier je suis
extrêmement déçu
j'ai l'impression que la protection de
l'enfance ça n'intéresse pas beaucoup
finalement la sénatrice de saône et
loire est à l'origine d'une loi qui
interdit depuis 2001 l'accès de ses
sites aux mineurs mais deux ans plus
tard cette protection n'est toujours pas
effective un enfant qui veut jouer en
ligne qui peut jouer de l'argent on peut
pas un enfant qui va aller consulter un
film pornographique payant une pop 1
puisque la ya tout simplement est de
facto un contrôle de l'âge puisqu'il
faut payer il faut une carte bancaire
mais les films gratuits voilà ton
pédaler avec les téléphones portables et
les tablettes la consommation de
contenus pornographiques explose les
professionnels de santé tire la sonnette
d'alarmé selon eux quatre enfants sur
dix de moins de 12 ans ont déjà vu un
film porno ça va provoquer un
traumatisme chez l'enfant au même titre
par exemple que la visualisation de
violences intra familiales ou tout autre
type de violence l'adolescent il n'est
pas en capacité de faire face à st donc
mais estime de soi des pressions à
impulsivité
non maîtrise de ses émotions à la maison
des adolescents de saône et loire près
de 700 jeunes sont suivis
individuellement les animateurs déplore
que la pornographie soit le principal
modèle d'éducation sexuelle des mineurs
d'autant qu'ils restent chez eux un
sujet tabou enlever l'accès au porno
c'est très bien dans tous les cas mais
après voilà à nous d'assurer en tant
qu'adulte sur l'éducation à la sexualité
à la vie amoureuse et
et voilà leur proposer autre chose
la justice vient de demander une
nouvelle médiation entre le régulateur
du numérique et les principaux sites
pour adultes elle aura lieu début
octobre